I reject nation it's Greg outta here and
I'm Stacy Howard Stacy Howard is here
with me today it is midnight guys yeah
we are here to watch the bumblebee
trailer that just dropped I loved the
teaser trailer we got I actually started
watching the Transformers part two in
the 1980s one yeah this show just
yesterday watch the first three episodes
and I was like oh now I'm actually
really excited to see you guys a couple
of things at our patreon we do
full-length TV show reactions Plus
weekly q and A's you should go check us
out since stacey is here with me at
midnight I feel it is right to promote
the main thing she is here for Stacey go
ahead tell them about it
right so Star Trek fans what's up guys
October 5th we are screening Star Trek 2
at the Wrath of Khan we're doing it at
the multi bond theater that's the
theatre that Ricardo Montalban Cod
himself started on the roof under the
stars doors open at 6:30 you guys can
get fun themed drinks like Romulan ale
you can take fun photos on the red
carpet you can win you know prizes with
trivia have q and a's with a lot of our
special guests like scott manse dan
merle mark nobec Robert Myer brunette
Jon Roca Jason Eman Ashley Robinson all
the best people you guys are gonna be
they're gonna be there right so come
hang out and then the movie starts at 8
o'clock you can get tickets at arena
screen dot-com so again this October 5th
start trick to the wrath of God at the
montalban on the roof be there or be BB
let's do this all right
[Music]
I've never been more excited for a
transfer Stanley okay here's kid
[Music]
what are you
[Music]
so you have no idea where he came from
no idea
[Music]
well yeah but people can be terrible
about things they don't understand don't
see that one yeah
whoa aleksander walk raging on our
planet
if this criminal isn't found that war
may find its way that a female sound
like my Ola Davis Oh
and an army Wow is in first hand these
things really that Cybertron
bumblebee there is only one way to end
this war
Wow let us protect earth and its people
whoa looks like new Star Wars
[Music]
Wow man pretty awesome
this is how we stop them
[Music]
oh you know what that was cute that
looks it's like horrible action it's
like a cross between a cool Transformers
movie with a really adorable story well
it's making me flashback to what the
first movies effect was supposed to be
with having that sense of a human
meaning this alien robot and having the
sense of wonder it's crazy to be yeah
exactly
I'm much like movies yeah for this to be
the sixth Transformers movie I know it's
an origin tale it's breathable and
everything but for it to be the sixth
one to actually be delivering and to
trailer so it makes me have the faith
that the movie will have it this sense
of wonder I'm really excited about that
because none of the other ones that
brought me that but this one's actually
bringing me that it's like it's finally
getting to the heart it's finally
getting to the place that we want it to
be at which is like you said wonder that
like childlike sense of yes covering
something that's your own yes not
something an adult has or a teacher gave
you or your parents made you watch it's
your own little secret yes yes because
what I'm finding myself most gravitated
towards is the personal tale here yeah
weirdly you know even though it's the
Transformers world I was like oh there's
a lot of action in this tree of course
is gonna be action in the movie but I
gotta say you know this is Travis Knight
and it's not Michael Bay but with the
action sequences the way they're lit the
way they're shot it's very crisp it's
very clear where there's a lot of
complaints about the Transformers movies
having kind of a chaotic looking dark
palette yeah it's gonna be hard to keep
up with the action and there's like a
machine yeah it's the overabundance of
explosions shaky camp and we're looking
at the action sequences here I'm like
this looks very clear and beautiful
always looks small yeah yeah it's not
this gigantic world the overall feel is
that it feels like it contained grounded
stories yeah we can keep up with I'm
putting myself out there to be educated
all right I'm all for you guys
informing me of who these others
transformers are and everything with
that from the looks of it like I said I
only just started the cartoon yesterday
it looks like they're on Cybertron at
the beginning of this because of the war
with the Decepticons and the Autobots
for my understanding bumblebee loses his
voice because of Megatron that's what I
was told and so I don't know if we're
gonna actually see that here because in
this trailer he doesn't have his voice
still he still have feel like this we'll
probably see the origin him how he gets
the radio voice that you see in the
Transformers movies but when they're on
Cybertron and you're seeing all the
different transformers it looks really
cool a different layer a different
element and it feels more like the show
to me than any of the transformer movies
have because one thing I was loving when
I was watching the show was this is
really about the Autobots and the
Decepticons and they all have
personalities and they all feel like
characters and one thing the
Transformers franchise has done so
consistently and is a failure on the
movies end is the Transformers their
personalities and then being characters
is so secondary to the human part I feel
like this is kind of a reintroduction in
a way because yeah Hailee Steinfeld's
the main character but bumblebee feels
like a real character and it feels like
the other transformers are also gonna be
full-fledged characters which is the
main thing we freaking needed in this
franchise that have full characters with
these Autobots this movie's giving me so
much to be excited about I'm really
looking forward to this movie I agree
and I haven't said that about
transformers mmm let's see ever yeah to
see this film and I'm invested in the
story already and I'm loving the look
I'm loving the vibe I'm loving the feel
that's big yeah for someone like me who
didn't watch the series growing up who
did not particularly enjoy the films
before this to look at this and say okay
now I want to see that now I'm
interested now that looks cool that
obviously is effective absolutely and
like there's fresh designs and from
other toy designs I've seen it it looks
like it's harkening back to some
original aesthetic which I'm very much
for I mean a big a big disappointing
element that people were feeling at a
Comic Con was this red looking
transformer people thought it was this
character called Starscream who I loved
you in the cartoon of the episodes I've
seen thus far parent
it's not that character because other
character thing called blitz Knight
could be wrong like I said willing to be
educated here because there's a war
raging on our planet
if this criminal isn't found when they
were seeing that care that transformer
talk sometimes when they see the
Transformers talking these movies it
looks a little strange and there was
that one transformer I don't really
remember the movies that well I've only
seen them one time and I barely remember
them is this the first female it sounded
like a female transformers yeah that'd
be the first one we've gotten I don't
know if I've heard a female transformer
before and I think that's pretty cool
cuz why wouldn't there be males and
females yeah exactly
because females are more as more of a
human concept you know transformer I
don't know I was thinking about that too
when I was watching this show like how
do they reproduce and they just built
more I'm not sure what they do small
like a baby girl they built a big I
don't know I don't know the anatomy or
their meaning rituals and I would like
for someone to explain that to me even
though like we've had so many
Transformers films like Megatron
civilian Optimus Prime is main
transformer Autobot it feels like
bumblebee will feel like a real defined
protagonist hero and it looks like we're
gonna have some real defined Decepticon
villains as well yeah what are these
things this movie is really leading with
its transformers having the personality
in the stakes in the story beyond trying
to get us invested in some [ __ ]
human character that's the other side
the human character here looks great
looks awesome in this movie you got the
BS part of it dev like them you know the
physics of like she's about running this
giant transformers what even the steps
are calls are like fall or something you
know that amount of chaos going on the
first teaser trailer really delivered
the heart and the Iron Giant vibes that
I was really drawn to and now this
trailer is showing us like don't worry
guys the action stuff will still be here
too and it'll be cool I just really hope
that it can tonally balance both I guess
that's my if I had a concern its
balancing the Transformers action and
that cool spectacle with having the
heart but honestly it's a very mild
concern I feel like it's gonna deliver
I've never been this excited for a
trance
man this looks really cool I'm really
excited for it I think it's gonna be I
think it's gonna be cool and different
and like a it's like a Clint Alec
cleanser from everything that we've had
and all the you know different problems
that people might have found yeah I just
got to go learn who these other
transformers are yeah but yeah anyway
guys thanks for watching Stacey thanks
for being here all the way freakin
midnight yeah you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and check us on
patreon TV show reactions weekly Q&A s
and also Arena screen comm for tickets
October 5th start talk to the Wrath of
Khan on the roof of the Montalban 8 p.m.